adesso basta scusate ma non avete dei
genitori ma è dove sono signora ma mi
scusi io adesso me ne sono neanche
riusciti a leggere una pagina di libro
per colpa di questi cosi qua ma scusi ma
non mi interessa se sono bambini ma una
maxi sono tantissimi abili che non fanno
tutto questo casino ma secondo lei fatto
70 euro dovrà fare per farvi strillare
nell'orecchio ma stiamo scherzando
per i giovani queste quelle che fanno
figli da giovani e poi non sanno neanche
guardare ma ci vada lei ma da uno bravo
anche maleducata va dalla spiaggia
pubblica no adesso voglio sapere chi è
stato a lanciare questo granello di
sabbia sul mio telo mare no mi interessa
se ne hanno fatto posto giovanni capito
e chi sbaglia paga cioè se iniziassimo a
ballare to primo madrid a rotoli o no
sarei passato certe botte da stamattina
non voglio niente non me ne frega anni
l'incarico e scegliendo come farai
capito i gioielli per il compro
gioielleria di casa buco prato giovanni
questo non è la morale va bene è io
lavoro faccio un mazzo così tutto l'anno
in vacanza le star tranquilla lo difendi
puro è ma che pirla che ho sposato lo
sai che servirebbero la buonanima di mio
nonno scorso ancora vivo si stava meglio
quando c'è la benito